well the new book is titled the third
lie and it's based on a old and not very
good joke that there are three lies and
the first one is this is the older part
of the joke of course i'll respect you
in the morning' and the second lie is
the check is in the mail and the third
lie is on from the government that I'm
here to help you and it spends about two
thirds of the book developing the case
that government social programs not
Public Works programs not highways or
national parks but social programs like
welfare and child abuse and special
education domestic violence food stamps
housing are essentially as bad as people
think they are that they are terribly
ineffective that the government does
generally a poor job of delivering the
help it is expected to deliver and the
authors of the program's want it to
deliver and there are a variety of
reasons for that from college professors
point of view one of the reasons is
there's a disconnect between research
and government social policies so is one
chapter called the drunken the lamppost
which says policymakers use research the
same way a drunk uses a lamppost much
more for support than for lumination but
underneath that the real issue is that
as a society we're really ambivalent
about do we really want to help and who
we want to help so we set up programs
that are safety net programs that almost
always have a means test welfare the
means test is well just how poor I you
housing the means test is well just how
much housing do you need special
education what's your disability and do
you in fact require special assistance
for domestic violence unfortunately the
means test is are you a victim of a form
of violence that's criminal for child
abuse the means test
is other caregivers inadequate in terms
of neglect or medical neglect of
physical abuse or sexual ease but but
almost every government program has this
means test which means there's an
enormous bureaucracy hired to decide
when the gate gets open and when the
gate gets closed and that diverts
monetary resources and energy that would
other by otherwise be spent on the
program itself the second ambivalence is
in fact at bright line who gets the
services and in the market economy we're
really reluctant to help everyone
because we think well you know one
exactly reward behavior that we think is
inappropriate so why would you have a
welfare benefit increase with a second
out-of-wedlock child when in fact we
don't want children born out of wedlock
to folks who aren't able to support them
so we we spend a great in in domestic
violence is a perfectly example what is
domestic violence is it physical abuse
is it emotional abuse is it sexual abuse
is it yelling is it male males exerting
power and privilege you know in the
beginning of the of the crusade to look
at the sexual assault I think Andrea
dwarkin once said that ninety-five
percent of all men are rapists well
that's a bit excessive and in essence
what she's saying is we don't need a
safety net we need a complete cultural
change which in fact was a point but
that's not going to get you very far in
an environment where the social policy
is means-tested so you know I spend
about two thirds of the book on that I
didn't stop and say has there ever been
a government program that's worked can
you put a lie to the lie and it's it's
not going I'm not going to give away the
whole book and we don't have time to
give away the whole book but they
essentially the government programs that
work are the ones that don't have means
test so i have really simple ones
my you know when I turn 65 I can ride on
the bus in Philadelphia for free what's
the means test they turn 65 I'm eligible
for Medicare and nobody comes and says
how much money do I make why because we
decided in 1965 that the elderly are
entitled to good health care nobody else
is but the elderly are can you in fact
build social policies based on that
principle and that's that's going you
have to buy the book to get the last
part
I think we needed decide what rights and
what up privileges I'm not in favor of
big government handout redistribution of
wealth I think it's not going to work in
our society it's not going to get votes
but there are certain things that we
might want to have a discussion about
such as is healthcare a universal right
is a quality education a universal right
is having decent housing a universal
right and how do you feel in a market
economy achieve that cost effectively
and I think we can do that but I think
there are other areas I think safety and
well being a universal rights but other
things probably not I mean we're not
going to go to a socialistic society
where each you know going back to marks
each according to his his or her needs
it's not going to happen so this this
right and universality discussion has to
be done in a society that is a market
driven society where we don't want to
reward certain behaviors because we
think they're the counter productive to
the kind of economic system we have
I think the public option is essential
everyone is entitled to health care
everyone isn't entitled to every test
under the Sun when you dig down and look
at medicare it's pretty obvious the
biggest funding the biggest cost of
Medicare which by the way is an
efficient program let's say right now
the administrative costs of Medicare at
two percent you find me a program that
runs on a two percent overhead rate and
I'll say that's an effective program but
the money spent on health care is all
back ended the majority money is spent
in the last two years of life and are we
making that investment in quality of
life in extending life or is it
defensive medicine to make sure we don't
get sued and you know i'm not talking
about death panels but i'm talking about
evidence-based medicine and also for the
first two years of life in medicaid
evidence-based medicine is not a lot of
point in investing millions of dollars
to create a low quality life so the
front end of life in the back end of
life yes and health care is an
entitlement but every possible form of
health care isn't an entitlement
the welfare system and I work when I one
year worked in Washington on the welfare
reform bill the welfare reform bill
worked because it has a time limit
because it says welfare is a temporary
right not a permanent right so even in
this economic recession with
unemployment going up the welfare rolls
are lower than they were in 1996 I think
that's about as much reform as you're
going to get where you need the reform i
think is too people have to have a stake
in society and they get that by having
homeownership I'm i look back to the
1950s and I think the the American
economy did the best when people were
able to buy homes and the consumer
society thrived not by buying an extra
plasma TV we're buying all the utilities
and appliances that go with home
ownership one of the great disasters of
2008 2009 is a decrease in homeownership
as a result of the the financial
problems of financial scandals with the
subprime mortgages
famila side as we understand it is when
one family member and not typically the
man but almost always the man kills the
spouse all of the children and then
himself as an act of suicide it is
pretty rare there seem to be two forms
of it one form is kind of the coercive I
own my wife and my children and
therefore I have a right to take them
with me if I no longer want to live and
there's a second type which is a little
bit more rare and that's the shame
famila side that occurs during economic
downturns when you no longer able to
support your spouse and your children
and you love them so much that you don't
want to shame them by exposing them to
this this failure of yours so you take
them with you so from a social
scientific point of view we call it over
a measurement but it's basically an
inability to see that your wife and your
children have separate existences from
your own now that's where it begins to
I'm not going to use the word bleed over
because it's going to be too
metaphorical but that's when it becomes
it looks a lot like the kind of power
and control homicides where you're
taking everybody with you in an active
of anger these the economically driven
famila sides aren't particularly violent
they don't leave they're not brutal they
use poison they use gas they use
suffocation the power and control famila
sides can be pretty brutal and pretty
bloody essentially sending a message you
failed me and I'm taking you out
it's not a bad argument the cult
argument it's a different kind of cult
it's a cult with the father husband
seeing himself as the head of the family
the king the Jim Jones and everybody's
going to drink the kool-aid because Jim
Jones doesn't want to be around any
longer I hadn't really thought of until
he asked the question but the cult mass
killings seem to also be male driven I
can't think on my own of the last female
cult leader who had a mass killing
involved with her they tend to be again
males who do this
they're variety of hypotheses about this
underneath almost all of it is the
desire to control the other people the
desire to be the person who achieves the
benefits and reduces the costs of
intimate relationships I think this is
the more complicated answer is we've
we've cast men in a role that they can't
all fulfill you are the head of the
family you're the breadwinner you're the
key decision-maker you're the king of
the mountain and and the reason was is
to fulfill that role of psychological
economic and social resources aren't
handed out evenly to every man so that a
good number of men are left with the
only resource they have is their
physicality and they use that to
compensate for the lack of other
resources and I think there's an
argument to be said for the shame that
goes with not being able to live up to a
feeling widespread cultural view of what
municipal to be like
extra Y chromosome out there there's no
birth defect out there the psychological
factors in there clearly are
psychological factors can't be viewed
independently of the social environment
in which men are brought up in I've seen
men who are really sociopathic we really
don't know right from wrong you say well
where did that come from well go back
into their childhood and you find out
that they received a good deal of head
trauma at the heads of their fathers or
you know growing up and so the clear and
significant psychological problems that
they have have a a social Genesis
I think that in the area of men and the
problem with men in the area of domestic
violence there's an intersection of the
the politics of social life with the
realities of social life and in 2009 a
goodly number of the advocates and those
in the research community sort of
putting their heads together and saying
who should we really be protecting we
spent a lot of time in the 1970s
broadening the definitions of child
abuse and broadening the definitions of
domestic violence to convince a pretty
apathetic public and pretty apathetic
policy community that domestic violence
was a legitimate social problem that
deserved a place on the policy agenda
and the funding agenda and the
institutional agenda and to a certain
extent we succeeded we probably
succeeded beyond our expectations
although it did take 30 years having
then succeeded we now look and say gee
you know maybe we are diluting our
efforts maybe the police don't have to
show up to every household with is
screaming and yelling and hitting maybe
in the effort to create this social
problem we've lost sight of the battered
women in child abuse it's you want to
keep kids from being spanked or do you
want to protect children who at risk of
being killed and in domestic violence
we're now grappling with with that issue
you know it's night it's 2009 and we
face the fact that resources are finite
they're never going to be I think we've
now given up the idea that they'll be
unlimited resources to deal with social
issues and social problems so now we
have to be realistic about what is it we
want to prevent it gets back to when I
started at the beginning what are people
entitled to they were entitled to be
safe
they're not necessarily entitled to live
in conflict free households kids are
entitled to adequate parenting but
they're not entitled to great parenting
and the idea that government has a role
in assuring great parenting a
conflict-free marriages or equity
between men and women I I just think is
not a viable position anymore